these are some questions that I'm going
to answer for the financial times that
they may use in an article that they're
going to do about the Khan Academy so
the first question to what do you
attribute your ability to effectively
digest synthesize and teach such a wide
variety of topics i guess i guess the
simple answer is is it i really enjoy
doing that and i think by a set of
circumstances either by you know the way
might maybe my brain works or or maybe
just circumstances or maybe ways that
I've been taught and I don't even
remember where that might have come from
I learned a long time ago that there's
kind of two ways to get by in in in our
system and I actually I say in our
system or maybe more broadly in society
you can go and look at knowledge is
something where you're memorizing things
or your pattern matching things or you
could look at it as something to
conceptually understand and digest and
synthesize and i think i was fortunate
enough at an early age to kind of be
much better the digestion and the
synthesis then at the memorization or
the pattern matching actually think i
have a quite quite a bad memory and and
so that's how i got that's how i think i
was able to do reasonably well
academically and then later on it
transferred over into into actually
contributing in you know and in my work
life and i think there's a natural high
and I don't think I'm unique there I
don't think there's any unique work to
my personality I think when people
really do learn things it's one of those
natural highs it's one of those things
that differentiate human beings from
most other animals is that we really
like learning we really like
understanding and we really are
naturally curious and so actually it's a
it's actually maybe a little sad that
more people aren't as excited about
trying to digest and synthesize a wide
variety of topics you know actually just
to focus on the second part a wide
variety of topics what's interesting
about that for me and I I learned a lot
of this to some degree from my my former
job working for an investment fund and
analyzing a bunch of different companies
in a bunch of different industries is
the more the more topics you look at the
more that you see that there are common
underlying themes and
the more connections you're able to make
and the more you're able to kind of have
a philosophy of how the world works and
so I actually don't even think I
actually think it it build your
understanding of every field the more
fuels that you look at and you're able
to see connections and if you just focus
on on one field it'll actually narrow
your view even of that of that one field
so the next question where does this
polymathics tree of such varied subjects
come from there are plenty of
intelligent people who could study up on
these subjects and not be able to
communicate them so effectively is
similar answer to last I thought
something to do the same answers the
last you know I I just I just I enjoy
looking at things I enjoy learning
things and I enjoy thinking you know I
like sitting on a park bench and just
thinking about things and you need
something to think about and so that's
why I like studying different topics and
I like seeing where there might be
parallels or where there might be aha
moments or where there might be magical
things about that subject that maybe
people didn't realize or maybe emphasize
properly you know the second part about
about not being able to communicate I
agree there are plenty of intelligent
people who could study up on these
subjects you know they're not being able
to communicate them effectively I think
there are people out there and and and
hopefully I'm hoping more and more of
them do decide to communicate them
effectively and I'm hoping that we can
find them and maybe they can they can
even join the Khan Academy faculty I
think the important thing that a lot of
people who do have subject matter
expertise I think they they sometimes
have the difficulty of getting them
getting into the mind of a learner and
and you know I'll be frank a lot of the
way I view the world is fairly I think I
have fairly simple models in my mind
that that and and I've gotten good at
taking complex things and creating
simple models in my own mind so that I
can work with those models and I think
some people are actually good at keeping
complicated models in their mind when
you have a complicated model in your
mind it's obviously much harder to
communicate them because it's
complicated but I think most of those
models can be distilled down to more
simple and more elegant ways of thinking
about things next question were you
always drawn to such a variety of
subjects how do you maintain your
curiosity is there anything that strikes
you is too dry to learn and teach you
know once again yes I was always drawn
well you know actually I'll take that
back early in my life there were there
were there were two things that I really
liked
I really liked I really liked art and
drawing and painting when I was very
early on you know it when I was actually
in school people viewed me as kind of
like the art guy the guy who would draw
pictures and cartoons and stuff like
that and I really enjoyed mathematics
what I didn't enjoy in my early
schooling is I wasn't a big fan of
reading and I wasn't a big fan of
writing in my early school and I viewed
as those things that I just wasn't good
at you know I actually used to sometimes
when I used to read I would just sit and
fixate on like one sentence and have to
read it over and over and over again I
would take me forever to read a page and
it was something that actually
frustrated me a lot and it wasn't until
later that I kind of I don't know to
some degree distressed how I viewed some
of those things and I let myself to
explore things without the stress of
judging myself for having other people
judge me that I started realizing wow I
actually do like reading and I really do
like writing and it's a form of
communication and I love just thinking
analytically about how do you make an
argument and I think the underlying
lesson there is is when you thought you
didn't like something and then you learn
that not only do not not like it but you
actually like it you're like well maybe
I'm prejudging everything you know so
the second part of this question is
there anything that strikes you is too
dry to dry to learn and teach no I mean
there's nothing there's there's things
that right now I perceive as dry but my
my gut feeling tells me that it's just
the way that it's been taught or
marketed to the world that meet people
make it drive you know one of my big
discoveries you know even something like
accounting you tell you tell someone
accounting and they think is this a stri
subject but I remember when I went when
I went to business school kind of this
big aha moment like this is a really
fascinating subject it isn't just about
being counting it isn't just about it
isn't just about bookkeeping it's about
using it's about using symbols and
numbers to reflect a certain reality of
what this business or this process is
actually doing and maybe you know when a
lot of people here that they still might
say well that's still not that but but
trust me it you know it can be a very a
very interest in fact this whole
financial crisis is driven by people's
different philosophies or understanding
of accounting so I think my philosophy
and I i haven't had a topic yet that
I've with is disproven this philosophy
is actually what's dry is how a topic is
presented
the topic itself so really almost any
topic is is can be very intellectually
interesting if it's looked at the right
way what do you do for fun what do you
read what movies films and arts do you
enjoy during your free time one can get
the impression that Khan Academy is all
you do in terms of fun and this an
answer has changed a lot over the last
three years since having children so my
my time is is limited now and you can't
do all the stuff that I used to like to
do I mean one of the things I used to
like to do when it was just me and my
wife or even before I was married I was
a big you know I liked the outdoors a
lot and like to go hiking and it's
something that I like I hope to do with
my children soon but they're a little
bit too young to go to go hiking or
camping just yet but but that is one of
the things that I really I really like
to doing you know just outdoors things
I'm also you know I'm a I'm a I'm a
hobbyist guitarist and painter and you
know I don't claim it all to be good at
those things but its stump there are
things that I like to do for fun I like
to you know their form of creative
expression in terms of what what do I
read I read a lot of science fiction
which may not surprised a lot of people
so a lot of science fiction and you know
frankly I also like to revisit a lot of
the books that I was forced to read so
to speak in in in high school and
college and now when I revisit them and
I'm reading them for fun I'm starting to
really enjoy them so I read frankly I
read a lot of science fiction and I and
I read a lot of the and I read a lot of
the classics for fun and I found that
they take on a new light one when you
read them for fun and when you read them
from you know you're a little older now
and you have a little bit more
perspective on life although you know
hopefully have a lot more perspective to
get so uh you know science fiction
they're fun you know they're fun by
themselves they tend to be good stories
but I just like what they kind of expand
your mind and really make you think a
lot of things that we take for granted
in our society science fiction books are
really good at kind of exposing them as
somewhat arbitrary and that there are
other ways to do things and I think it
really are that there are some of the
best things you can read to expand your
view of what is possible and you say
what movies films and arts do you enjoy
during your free time
um you know I know once agai I love
science fiction i love i love epic
things generally you know so whether
it's Braveheart or more of the rings or
the or the Godfather movies and you know
I don't think I'm alone and liking those
type of things but you know we've been
what you know but my wife every now and
then gets me to watch an episode of
felicity on on netflix and I enjoy that
too which is a little bit embarrassing
but anyway one could get the impression
that Khan Academy is all you do well you
know it's a lot of what I do now
especially with children I think you
know I try to you know during the day
focus Khan Academy in the evening focus
on wife and children but within that
context as much you know I I try to you
know at least have one good book to read
while I'm traveling or maybe right
before right before I go to bed and you
know now that my kids are getting a
little rum getting a little bit more
time to go back to do a little bit of
the outdoor stuff and a little bit of
the the the creative projects what do
you what do you want Khan Academy
curriculum to encompass is AK through 12
basics on math and science source is
broader than that will it ever be
complete the second answer is easy to
answer no it will never be complete I
think there's an infinite number of
topics to cover and I think we can
always improve on what's covered and we
can always a tackle it from a different
angle so that I don't think it will ever
be complete is it it isn't just K
through 12 basics in fact even now it
isn't just cake through a K through 12
basics there's a lot of content about
college level material even graduate
level material there's stuff about
economics and finance and we've just
brought on to our history professors who
are doing so they're the new first
additions to the Khan Academy faculty
and they're doing art history really had
a fairly advanced level and we're trying
to do some videos with professors that
you know Stanford Medical School in
other places where we're attacking even
you know medical stuff so there's no end
and you know we really want to encompass
everything that is helps people form a
view of the world and understand the
world around them and become productive
and happy and and at people with rich
lies okay so it's pretty much everything
next question as Khan Academy continues
to find a larger audience you have any
concerns about a growing number of
students learning from one source is
there a risk of having a uniformity of
primary materials for students we think
about this issue and you know this is
why we are expanding the faculty and
there's actually going to be someone who
joins also on the math side and she's
going to teach some she teaches things
it's a slightly different view although
I think we have similar sensibilities
and so our goal is to iterate and you
know and we're actually starting to get
more analytical about what makes a video
good what makes you know and so if
someone makes another good video on
something or there's another way to view
things we hope to include those in the
library we don't think we'll have a
million different teachers but we think
we on a topic you might have two or
three different viewpoints on something
and we think we think that's good and
we're also starting to introduce across
the board and we've done this with the
medicine videos and some of the
economics videos is we're starting to
have conversations in our videos and
this is what the the two art historians
do Beth Harris and Steven Zucker they
have our conversations so it's it's them
to talking about a piece of art or me
and a professor talking about some
scientific phenomenon so you're really
getting a conversation and seeing that
there's there's two sides to it and
frankly I think it's better that you
know there's there's a you can go to
university that has many professors but
when you take intro to American history
you get only one source you're getting
that one professor or there is only one
textbook right now that you know
dominates what each field so we actually
we can provide more voices than what is
traditionally provided you know the
powerful thing about the internet now is
I don't think anyone can capitalize as
one voice and if anyone did and
especially if that was bad quality they
would lose they will people because the
internet gets rid of all intermediaries
there's no gatekeepers anymore it's not
like we're publishing firm 50 years ago
where you know only what's published is
what people get at now people can get
anything anywhere and frankly you know
anyone can do it frankly what I did over
YouTube and and people are and I think
that's that's a really healthy thing
that you can always get the the other
points of view next question why are you
focusing on education um I guess the
simple answer is you know I guess this
may be all together you concern about
the state of public education you know
it's I regardless of whether we are all
professional educators we've all spent a
significant time in the education system
I'm no exception and you know I did just
have a nagging feeling while I went
through it
there's got to be a better way to do
this I saw how many students were
pattern-matching how many were
memorizing how little retention people
have how much resources people have and
and and still not coming out the other
side having done creative things having
kind of really stretch their thinking
and so it seems like you know we're at
an inflection point in history and you
know this is the information revolution
and it's crazy that almost every other
field is is is getting is getting
revolutionized except for education so I
think it's it's just right for it and
you know just answering some of those
early questions about my interest it's
what I love doing I i entered the
investment world because you know i
loved learning about different issues i
love talking to a egg producer one hour
and talking to a railroad company the
next hour and talking to a software
company the next hour and talking to a
natural gas pipeline owner the next hour
because you'd learn how the world works
and you know edge that's what education
is learning how the world works learning
ways of thinking and it would sometimes
with the goal of becoming a productive
happy member of society and with a rich
life and so you know I can't imagine
anything better to focus yes this is a
simple answer because it also you know
it's not it's it's something that's
interesting to me personally but then
obviously it can scale now and then it
just has it ripple effects that can that
can go on for not just for a few years
it can go on for generations so it's
it's it's it's it's kind of one of these
epic ideas and you know iris LG I like I
like epic things are you concerned about
the state of public education in the US
you know I'm concerned about the state
of public education everywhere in fact
i'll say i'm just i'm concerned about
the state of education everywhere you
know I'm it's I frankly you know people
dump on the public schools a lot but i
don't think the private schools are
actually much better i mean they're
selecting for students who probably
would do well if you gave them a
textbook and you know who come from
college educated families who are
wealthy who can afford private tutors
they charge them you know out here the
bay area 30,000 a year I don't know what
they're doing with those resources and
you know you don't see substantially
different results from private schools
charging thirty thousand dollars a year
to the public schools that are serving
the same demographic they seem to be
about the same or some of those public
schools are even better so I actually
think the whole models and you know it's
even true of them
at the you know people talk about our
university system as is the best thing
art there they do good research that's
why they're famous that's why they are
but in terms of how they're teaching
there's nothing that I find particularly
groundbreaking or you know something's
like you can't improve upon it i think i
think there's there's a lot that can be
done so i'm actually just concerned
about the general state of i actually
waited say education i'm concerned about
the general state of peoples of people's
learning in life irrespective of what
the education system is doing what are
your thoughts on the importance of
primary education as a means to a
productive and prosperous society I mean
that's what it's all about you know if
you don't have that primary education
there's no way to have a productive and
prosperous society I mean you need basic
security you need basic infrastructure
and you need an educated population if
it's it's now true more than ever you
know and back in the old days there were
jobs where you know just raw labor was
relevant but that's you know with
technology that becomes less and less
relevant every day and so in order for
people to be productive and to
contribute and to be to feel needed they
really have to step up the chain and you
know you know raw labors you needed less
and less because of mechanical
technology and because of information
technology kind of process oriented
white collar work is also going to go
away it's going to push everyone the
really needed jobs are the highly
creative ones and so it's not good
enough just to teach people how to you
know some process or some formula or
some pattern matching we have to teach
them to be creative we have to teach
them to innovate to problem solve things
that they've never seen before and so
yeah I think that's it's not it's not
just an ingredient it's actually the
foundation of having a productive and
prosperous society the last question is
it your hope that Khan Academy can help
reverse some of the losses we have
suffered in the quality of public
schooling you know just going to the
previous education it's you know I don't
think it's about public schooling or
private schooling or primary or
secondary education I think it's about
just I hope I hope it can help elevate
the state
of knowledge or learning generally and I
think we're you know I won't make any
bold claim that we've solved the problem
yet or we're anywhere close to it but I
think what's exciting about Khan Academy
is that we have a lot of traction and
where we're trying to be as thoughtful
about improving on what we have so you
combine the traction with our ability to
iterate move quickly and improve and
hopefully a thoughtful way and we can
only get better and I think we're really
just in the top of the first inning and
there's a long way to go here but I'm
hoping that it can improve the state of
of how people how people learn generally